[Música]
economía aquí en directo américa me
acompaña en el estudio jorge hurtado
forge muy buenas noches comenzamos en
europa porque allí la comisión europea
indicó que el corte del suministro de
gas ruso podría hundir el pib de la
euros
de la eurozona que cifra estamos
hablando santiago bueno según esta nueva
estimación en el escenario más pesimista
la inflación ahí se dispararía hasta el
9% esta nueva proyección del producto
interno bruto de la eurozona sería este
año del 27 % más de un punto por debajo
de su cálculo anterior pero de
concretarse un corte total del
suministro del gas ruso y la zona
crecería apenas un 0,2 por ciento de las
nuevas previsiones presentan la que la
inflación sería del 61 por ciento del
6,8 por ciento respectivamente para este
y el próximo año escuchamos un poco que
decían allí
los softwares las ondas de choque de la
invasión rusa de ucrania están resonando
en todo el mundo el impacto directo está
relacionado con el colapso de la
actividad y el comercio en todo el
vecindario oriental de la unión europea
indirectamente las repercusiones
negativas sobre la demanda mundial
proceden del aumento de los precios de
los productos básicos la interrupción
del suministro de materias primas e
insumos intermedios el agravamiento del
cuello de botella del transporte y el
endurecimiento de las condiciones de
financiación es financing condicións
bulgaria pedirá a la unión europea
quedar exenta del planeado de embargo el
crudo ruso asilo no es el primer
ministro de bulgaria quien el petró
durante una rueda de prensa en sofía con
su homólogo en adelante el argumento es
que su única refinería sólo puede
procesar el tipo de petróleo que le
compra a rusia hablemos ahora de china
porque la economía de este país se
contrajo por los confinamientos
principalmente el de shanghai el puerto
más importante del mundo allí la
actividad económica cayó en su mayor
contracción en dos años y medio los
cierres que han persistido durante
varios meses llegaron a shanghai que
aporta el 5 por ciento el producto
interno bruto chino y está generando un
impacto negativo en las cadenas de
suministro y el consumo los datos
muestran que la producción industrial
cayó un 2,9 por ciento en abril con
respecto al año anterior y mucho menos
que el 5% que había registrado en marzo
mientras que las ventas al por menor se
redujeron un 11% interanual shanghai
rebajar a las medidas desde el primero
de junio según anunció el gobierno del
confinamiento será de forma gradual y
hablemos ahora de eeuu porque aumentan
las posibilidades de una recesión
económica esto sin duda alguna traerá
consecuencias mundiales y es que según
la última encuesta realizada por
bloomberg a los economistas esa
posibilidad aumentó un 30 por ciento y
es la más alta desde la pandemia la
cifra es un poco superior al 27 5% de
abril y duplica las probabilidades de
que los economistas preveían hace apenas
tres meses la encuesta se realizó entre
el 6 al 11 de mayo e incluido las
respuestas de 37 economistas con la
inflación en su nivel más alto en cuatro
décadas deja la reserva federal con la
opción de agresiva subida de los tipos
de interés esto para tratar de enfriar
la economía pero con el riesgo de que la
economía no caiga una recesión y
hablemos ahora de colombia que presentó
sus datos de crecimiento del primer
trimestre del 2022 por favor que sean
noticias positivas bueno algo así la
economía colombiana creció un 8,5 por
ciento en el primer trimestre de 2022 en
comparación con el período anterior
según el gobierno el director del dane
dijo que el comercio de manufactura y
las actividades artísticas fueron las
que más aportaron en los tres primeros
meses de este año el sector artístico
colombiano registró un crecimiento
económico del 35 7% en el primer
trimestre en comparación con el mismo
trimestre del año anterior mientras que
el sector de la información y las
comunicaciones se expandió un 20,6 por
ciento pero los sectores agrícola y
financiero se contrajeron un 2,5 por
ciento y un 32 por ciento respecto al
período anterior si se compara con el
cuarto trimestre 2021 la economía
colombiana se expandió apenas un 1%
colombia es la cuarta economía de
américa latina hay mucha expectativa por
sus próximas elecciones presidenciales
pasamos ahora los indicadores como las
faldas principales bolsas del mundo
jorge empezamos con wall street que
cerró con resultados mixtos el nasdaq
un 120 por ciento tras unas semanas de
gran volatilidad en europa el selectivo
de fráncfort cerró con una bajada del
0,45 por ciento tras la publicación de
los datos económicos débiles de china y
el de la zona euro que mencionábamos
antes en américa latina' el mercado
brasileño de acciones se mantuvo en
terreno positivo alineado con el
escenario externo y la cifra del día
para el cierre la cifra del día es 3
billones de dólares eso añadiría el
metaverso al producto interno bruto
mundial una década después de su
adopción
el aporte sería aproximadamente del 2,8
por ciento del pib mundial para 2031
según la firma estadounidense analysis
group que es especializada en informes
económicos porque muchas gracias punto
final a la economía aquí en directo
américa y damos paso al debate
[Música]